un instant. D'abord un
avec Marie Michelle Lauzon.
- Les insectes sont en déclin
partout dans le monde.
C'est ce que révèle une étude
britannique publié dans
la revue "Nature". En 30 ans,
la population des insectes
a chuté de 50 % à certains
endroits, principalement
dans les régions tropicales.
MAXIM LARRIVÉE, directeur,
Insectarium de Montréal
- C'est simplement une preuve
de plus, celle-ci est globale,
qui confirme la tendance lourde
de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité entomologique
depuis les années 1990.1990.199.
- Au banc des accusés :
les changements climatiques
et l'agriculture intensive.
Le phénomène est observé aussi
au Canada, mais ila, mais ila, e
d'avoir un portrait exact
de la situation. Il existe
très peu de données disponibles.
CHRISTIAN HÉBERT, conservateur
de l'Insectarium René-Martineau
- Ça veut pas dire qu'on
n'a pas d'espères menacées,
mais je dirais que ce qu'on
observe dans les dernières
années en rapport avec le
changement climatique,
c'est plutôt l'inverse.
C'est qu'on voit des espèces
arriver arriver arriver arriver.
Ce ne sont pas des espèces
qui sont problématiques.
Plus la population mondiale
va monter, plus on va avoir
besoin de zones agricoles,
et plus on a besoin de zones
agricoles, plus ça entraine
nutions de population
d'insectes. C'est un cercle
vicieux.
- S'ajoutent à l'équation
certaines maladies que
les insectes peuvent développer.
En Estrie, certains apiculteurs
ont perdu 70 % de leurs
abeilles. Le MAPAQ a ouvert
une enquête. L'hypothèsepothèsee
d'un parasite viral
pourrait en être la cause.
ORGE JULIAN HERNANDEZ,
administrateur, Ferme St-Élie
- Le grand problème,
cette année, avec les abeilles,
il y en a pas. Nous autre,
on dépend de ça, ce sont
les abeilles qui font le g
travail, en fait. Fait qu'il
faut mettre les chances
de notre côté puis augmenter
la biodiversité.
- Tout le dossier des abeilles,
on en parlait encore ce matin,
là, mais ça, c'est quelque chose
qui est très préoccupant.
- Le MAPAQ a d'ailleurs lancé
en octobre 2021 le réseau
québécois en recherche
ulture durable,
un projet mobilisant
plus de 200 chercheurs.
ANDRÉ LAMONTAGNE, ministre
de l'Agriculture du Québec
- Au ministère, on a lancé
des recherches.
C'est certainement inquiétant
parce qu'on sait à quel point
les polinisateurs,er
important. C'est vital pour
notre industrie bioalimentaire.
Alors, oui, il y a
une préoccupation.
- Il exide
25 000 espèces d'insectes
au Québec. Même si aucun n'est
réellement en danger
d'extinction, l'urgence d'agir
téger notre biodiversité
est bien réelle.
Ici Marie-Michelle Lauzon,
Radio-Canada, Mon